this is from Harry K and Virginia Beach
big fan of the show listen to all your
podcasts so I made a short song for you
guys from last week
it's my remix of the Al Pacino margarita
dance I don't remember the margarita
dance but apparently there were I think
Al Pacino said give someone a margarita
I think maybe last week and so Harry has
taken upon himself to turned it into a
dance mix that was just at the right
time thank you was awesome one more time
man one more time we cue that up going
off well I think I think someone was in
the shoutouts early last week and we
bought her a margarita and then we found
out there was a pregnant woman in the
audience and I bought her a margarita
too and I think I think I did this
Pacino and I think that's where that
came from
but we do have a Hollywood helper this
week this is a celebrity goes out of his
way to do something nice for someone
who's not another celebrity which is
rare yeah we'll say what we call the
Hollywood helper
thanks mister thanks mister we needed a
new jingle man you said that last week
[Music]
hold on let me give him attractive
ladies do it everyone shut up already
mix this in margarita man Hollywood help
her Hollywood help her there you go he
could send it back next week he's gonna
send it that he can jump it into the
margarita mix so it goes Hollywood help
Uncle Rita's but this is a sweet segment
about nice things happening for nice
people and that's a very sweet song not
everything has to be get your [ __ ] out
it has to be filth and disgusting this
okay sometimes we can do something nice
this song sounds like the Hollywood
helper song now sounds like a Catholic
Mass like it's not celebratory nobody
wants to be there BAM but more
margaritas you just wanna you're like
let's honor him with margaritas
[Music]
you
[Music]